[Music]
the world now is the best it's ever been
if you want to be someone who just keeps
learning
there was a lot of aspiration within the
program the
faculty and guest speakers all brought
in extremely valuable insights and i
really appreciated this program
it actually ended up being a really
interactive experience
that afforded significant time to deal
one-on-one or in small groups with the
other members of the cohort
and i thought that that was that was
incredibly valuable time the online
module was excellent it exceeded my
expectation
it was so well curated that
it really felt like we were in class
you really have the opportunity to
engage in people not only within the
class and within your cohort
but certainly offline as well there are
friends that i've made in this program
that i really intend to keep in touch
with the rest of my life
i never imagined the program to be as
impactful as it was
i think you should feel very very
comfortable participating in any
online executive education program that
stanford offers
[Music]